salut tout le monde suite des portraits
en vue de la draft NBA 2023 portrait des
candidats évidemment des joueurs qui
sont candidats puisqu'on a la liste
définitive et que on vous donne
l'essentiel en 20 minutes sur les
joueurs principaux ceux qui pourraient
faire une belle carrière pour leur pour
vous donner un peu le les clés pour
comprendre leur jeu ce podcast est dédié
à qui on the
on va s'intéresser donc à Kyota George
né le 8 novembre 2003 il a donc déjà 19
ans et il aura 19 ans le soir de la
draft 1m93 84 kg arrière de l'équipe de
baylord les berz cette année il est vu
12e sur notre big board à l'heure à
laquelle on enregistre ce 14 juin 11e
chez the Ringer et un peu plus bas chez
ispienne et yatletic 17ème et 18e pour
en parler Hugues Thomas salut les gars
bonjour bonsoir tous et à tous également
bonjour à tous
et donc Hugues qui va nous faire
l'historique de qui on était George d'où
vient-il est-ce qu'il a des signes
particuliers au niveau de la coiffure et
ce qu'il a des passions et puis surtout
l'environnement
familialmont ça peut prêt ok pour notre
ami qui en tête
qui du coup lui a grandi dans le Texas
donc il y a revenu pour son université
c'était une des stars lycéennes il a
fait trois ans dans le Texas et puis il
est parti comme beaucoup d'entre eux
faire une année à imdj Academy qui a des
plus gros programme de School en Floride
donc il est passé de la de la country au
joli plage floridienne et puis du coup
pendant son tout son programme Elissa il
a été très convoité un très tôt des
décès de premières années par des I Met
Your donc il y a eu Texas Texas qui
Florida et j'en passe et j'en passe et
finalement il a choisi baylord pour le
grand plaisir pour ceux qui le savent
pas c'est une équipe qui m'est cher et
que j'aime beaucoup
avant ça il a alors c'est un des plans
de me fie en arrière-plan je suis un peu
désolé
c'est le travail de daron avant ça
effectivement il a participé au
McDonald's au Lamary 15 et on écoute etc
et puis surtout il a gagné lui aussi
comme gwy Dick dont on a parlé où on
parlera dans un podcast en fonction de
comment est sortiront le FIBA trois
contre trois des moins de 18 où il est
MVP pour le coup lui de ce championnat
là voilà pour notre ami qui ont été
Daniel j'ai passé la parole je pense à
Thomas qui est complètement fan à juste
petite parenthèse il était top 6 yes
bien c'est un jour très très attendu
cinq étoiles donc sixième ISBN ne vienne
pour 240 etc donc un joueur qui vraiment
était très attendu en amont de cette
saison 2022 2023 NCA voilà je précise
quand tu dis 6e c'est le le ranking des
recrues qui est fait par rapport à leur
à lie school donc le ranking des recrues
est pas forcément par rapport à la draft
c'est à dire qu'il les classes en termes
de valeur un peu absolu en sortant du du
High School et ensuite ça se modifie un
petit peu dans la perspective de la NBA
malgré tout c'est vrai que il était sans
doute vu plus haut dans les bords en
début d'année qu'aujourd'hui un petit
peu glissé
quel était son rôle cette année du côté
de Baylor Thomas alors cette année-là
elle arrive dans une équipe un corps
compétitive il jouait dans une sweet
girl line up avec LG Cryer et Adam
Flagler donc un trio vraiment offensif
de chaque Maker les trois joueurs
mettaient plus de 15 points donc c'est
vraiment le gros de l'attaque de baylord
trois square qui se partager un peu les
munitions là dedans qui ont des George
ils pouvaient avoir donc des munitions
ballonnement et je veux également pas
mal love ball notamment à trois points
après un énorme volume d'eau shoot à 3
points 14 300 prix par son possession
c'est vraiment énorme qu'il a réussi à
34% pas une réussite incroyable mais
très très grande diversité diversité de
tir pardon un soulignant on en reparlera
plus tard défensivement vu que on était
dans une équipe qui joue avec trois
couloirs et qu'il est assez costaud
physiquement il a pu tenir
principalement un peu délier vu que les
deux joueurs qui partagent le bac courte
sont des des gourds qui font un peu un
peu moins d'un mètre 90 un peu moins
tanqués physiquement donc voilà ça se
partage un peu les tâches défensif pour
essayer de de faire le travail
offensivement satirait énormément à
trois points c'est plus de 50% de ses
tirs 60% des 3 points étaient suivis
précédentes d'une passe décisive mais il
y a quand même pas mal de création
personnelle donc voilà ça se Correc ça
faisait un peu de pas assez quand même
20% d'assistes donc c'est un chiffre
vraiment intéressant surtout par rapport
à ce qu'il faisait en ice School en ice
couloir pour parler un peu de son
contexte High School donc comme l'a dit
XT très très gros joueur AMG on est à
jour beaucoup moins un passeur il a su
beaucoup progresser là-dessus on était
sur le cinquième passeur de son équipe
en termes de volume alors qu'il était la
principale menace offensive et le joueur
qui avait le plus la balle donc il y a
une vraie évolution là dessus donc c'est
toujours intéressant à souligner donc
cette année contexte pour conclure trois
points à gogo une diversité intéressante
un peu de shoot à l'intérieur il a eu
quelques difficultés défensivement ça se
partager les tâches défensives entre
trois guards un peu undersize
merci Thomas Hugues qu'est-ce qu'on
achète chez Guillaume et George quand on
quand on le projette en NBA quand on va
le drafter toi tu l'as douzième sur ton
big board donc l'autre il pique
ouais c'est un joueur qui
qu'on va prendre pour sa capacité à
créer son propre c'est un jour
normalement qu'on devrait
prendre pour être un scorer handball
alors pas forcément premier option mais
pourra peut-être une deuxième troisième
option offensive balle en main un joueur
qui va apporter vite du spacing et puis
on va le drafter parce qu'on a pu voir
sur deux contextes différents une
évolution assez forte donc un mec qui
s'est adapté son son jeu en fonction de
ce qu'on lui demande de faire énorme
scorer en High School ou il répond
présent et dans une équipe de belor on a
découvert un qui ont été George très
appliqué défensivement
pour venir sur bellor faut comprendre
que le leur meilleur défenseur c'est cet
effet les médicaments croisés donc été
pas là et sur les postes dédiés et ils
ont recruté un transfert de what the
Virginia challenge bridges qui a un peu
déçu par rapport à ce que Jérémie Soran
faisait l'an dernier donc
c'était pas évident et lui il a vraiment
step up sur plusieurs secteurs donc on
va acheter d'abord le shotmaking en
première en première position Thomas
elle l'a dit un gros volume de tir à
trois points avec beaucoup de poulet et
puis on va acheter un corps aussi qui
sans être un athlète énorme dans toutes
les dimensions explosivité ou
verticalité un joueur qui est déjà bien
puissant bien tanqué et qui va pouvoir
réussir à mener du de l'impact et gagner
des joutes dans les premières années
rapidement
Thomas esquête à d'autres qualités que
Hugues n'a pas mentionné qui que tu
aimerais ajouter au tableau de de
positif de qui on the George
personnellement je suis un peu moins
chaud sur son scoring au global par
rapport à ce que j'attendais en High
School il m'a pas mal déçu notamment à
deux points après sa principale qualité
comme l'a dit que c'est son 3 points ça
diversité trois points on parle beaucoup
quand on nomme les meilleurs shooters de
cette cuvée Brandon Miller get Awards
etc mais je pense que qui ont déjà
malgré son 35% à son 34 % de réussite
doit pas être obligé de cette liste car
aucun des joueurs précédemment cités non
le bug et la diversité qu'il a trois
points il est capable de se correr en
cas de Chen après mouvement il peut se
relocaliser des deux côtés pour recevoir
la Palma droite main gauche il a une
très grosse range de Thierry peut jouer
de l'isolation donc c'est vraiment très
très gros shooter à trois points très
complet très polyvalent donc ça c'est
très intéressant parce que j'ai beaucoup
aimé cette année c'est que comme l'a dit
Hugues en High School c'est un scorer
défensivement il y avait quelques flashs
quand il aimait bien jouer darrit
notamment les trois fois ils sont
affrontés il aimait bien montrer que
c'était un peu lui le mal dominant mais
il y avait
un peu beaucoup moins de défense quand
même il y avait beaucoup moins de
playmating et cette année même s'il a un
peu déçu au niveau de son scoring
notamment intérieur il a pu montrer il a
pu step up en défense il a pu c'était au
playmaking vraiment donc ces deux axes
de progression ont été très intéressants
ce qui l'aide après une saison à
seulement 38 % au tir à garder un stock
de draft intéressant car il avait su
montrer beaucoup plus polyvalent que que
l'on attendait en fait donc c'est ça qui
est très intéressant dans cette saison à
mes yeux ne pas forcément se fier au
stade si on regarde la comparaison la
plus adéquate en termes de stats avancée
sur les dernières années c'est Anthony
Edwards qui sort
à l'énorme différence près quand Tony
Edwards était une machine près du cercle
il jetait quasiment à 70% au Cercle
alors qu'il jouait dans une équipe de
mecs qui savaient pas shooter mais
sinon sur le le profil statistique on va
dire c'est à peu près similaire moi
j'avais une autre comparaison et c'est
pour ça que je l'ai un peu plus bas en
fait ce qui n'est pas si grand que ça
qui est pas aussi grand aussi costaud
qu'Anthony Edwards
c'est koh-lantoni
et est-ce que vous pouvez me dire ce
qu'il a de plus que koh-lantoni qui est
tu es aussi un gros joueur au lycée qui
lui aussi un peu déçu dans sa première
année enfin dans son année à
l'université qui lui aussi un
topshotmaker qui s'est faire quelque
part qui est plutôt à droite au tir
théoriquement et qui a un peu de mal
quand même à s'imposer à une bière même
si il fait carré
colonne bon déjà défensivement qui ont
été Georges à montrer un placement et
une comment dire une intelligence de QI
de fin de jeu dans ses rotations que
colonne Tony n'a jamais pu montrer qui
ont été pris énormément de passage en
force à sacrifier son corps bellor est
une une exigence défensive quand même de
très haut niveau même s'ils ont un peu
sous performé cette deux dernières
années donc là dessus comment dire vrai
vrai bonne capacité et qui ont des
George je pense à comment dire les
capacités à marquer sur du Nouan alors
il va que 15% de ses tirs sont pris près
du panier mais il faut survêt à 50 à
37%. ce qui est énorme c'est à dire que
c'est un joueur qui a pas souvent au
cercle mais qui sait vraiment créer du
contact et faire tomber les fautes donc
j'ai un peu plus confiance là-dessus et
pour moi il a vraiment sous performé
dans dans cette sorte qu'on regarde les
shots il y a que du bleu partout et
c'est fin donc c'est
plus c'est rouge dans les choses charges
souvent genre
notre ami qui ont été Georges voilà
c'est très faible notamment sur le mi
distance
ou il a il a vraiment été en grande
galère mais mais je pense que voilà le
il a fait une année sans je dis pas que
ça va être un All Star en NBA mais que
ce sera ça devrait être mieux que ce
qu'il a pu proposer cette année est-ce
que
ce que tu vois de lui psychologiquement
peut te rendre optimiste justement par
rapport à cet avenir et à sa progression
il a une mentalité de pyromane alors on
le on en parle souvent des mecs qui
prennent feu mais très grosse confiance
en lui quand il prend il prend des tirs
de très loin puis quand il en prend un
il a tendance à vouloir en prendre un
deuxième un troisième c'est un joueur
qui a qui a vraiment pu faire basculer
des fins de match après c'est aussi un
joueur qui lorsqu'il est en difficulté
peut se frustrer donc des up and donne
c'est pour ça que au départ je vais
espérer une des premières années en
sortie de bande en tout cas une première
année en sortie de banc
avec un meilleur porteur de balle à côté
de lui ce qu'il a pas forcément eu aber
l'heure on avait beaucoup de shooter on
n'avait pas de vrais général j'aimerais
bien qu'ils dans une équipe où il est un
joueur référencé ça tombe bien parce que
dans le top dans le top 15 toutes les
équipes ont un fort portant de balles
déjà et qu'on puisse le développer
tranquillement là dessus au pire ça sera
un bon un bon site Diamond 7e homme en
sortie devant et c'est déjà pas si mal
Thomas qui est le quel skill il aura
travaillé en priorité et si et si ça
marche bien quel plafond tu vois à qui
on était George quel genre de joueurs ça
peut devenir d'ici trois quatre cinq ans
son plus gros effet pour moi cette choré
efficacement à deux points c'est là où
il m'a vraiment déçu cette saison c'est
pas un joueur très très athlétique
premièrement surtout explosif explosif
il faut dire qu'il a donné quelques
trois fois cette saison donc c'est
vraiment assez peu et quand on voit sur
sur la répartition des tirs on voit que
15% de tirs haussière qu'on voit
quasiment 25 30% de Bitcoin mais c'est
un peu des stats en trompe l'oeil car
dans les midraines ça compte les Runner
les flotteurs etc en fait la plupart de
ces midrange sont des drives qui n'ont
pas abouti et qui ont fini dans un dans
un flotteur dans un Runner un peu
casse-croûte donc c'est un joueur qui
prend vraiment peu de mid range
contrairement à ce qui est marqué dans
les stats c'est souvent des ranges
forcés
de créer la séparation sur drive il
était moins explosif qu'on aille school
également faut dire que Scott de roue
qui au combat immense de bailar était
allé au combat il a dit qu'il avait
perdu 10 kilos entre la fin de ces
années High School et au moment du
combat donc c'est vraiment extrêmement
important et souligner il était un peu
c'est un peu un corps c'est pas un corps
très très tanqué c'est encore un peu un
peu gras il était un peu ok ouais voilà
c'est ça il aurait en lui quoi
clairement et apparemment donc selon ce
code Drew il aurait perdu 10 kilos en
gros une grosse année quoi donc c'est à
souligner peut-être on pourrait le
retrouver qui ont peut-être genre plus
explosif il faut aussi dire que c'est
sur ces pourcentages qui n'étaient déjà
pas très bons il a fini l'année blessée
et donc il met neuf de ces 40 derniers
tirs quand en revenant blessure en
forçant un peu pour essayer de jouer la
marche Madness on voit qu'il était
clairement pas en forme donc moi je vais
attendre de lui de mieux créer de la
séparation pour pour finir aussi comme
l'a dit ubilaine capacité incroyable à
mettre des end one personnellement
depuis que je le suis en High School
charmant vu mettre un joueur mette
autant de tir indécent et faire toucher
il est capable de mettre des tirs qui
sont vraiment dénués de sens en fait on
se dit comment il peut parquer il va
envoyer un Runner à 3 points
complètement fou donc c'est vraiment un
genre qu'un sens du panier même s'il a
été mis en difficulté cette année pour
faire deux points je vais attendre de
lui de mieux créer de la séparation de
se créer plus de mes distances également
utiles capable de créer son tir à trois
points je vais l'attendre qu'il est pas
assez souvent ancien que plus créer de
mes distances après du Bic également il
a ce poula il a se toucher il doit être
capable il a un terrible assez solide
également il s'est tribué demain je le
trouve assez propre là-dedans même s'il
a accordé des petits défauts donc je
trouve que c'est un T1 vraiment
intéressant il peut continuer de
progresser offensivement comme l'a dit u
je pense que c'est plus un joueur qui
doit qui doit sortir du pain pour
l'instant au vu de ses qualités et
personnellement comme l'a dit moi j'aime
bien son son mindset je trouve que c'est
un joueur qui joue avec son corps avec
son cœur pardon c'est un joueur qui a
toujours joué avec son cœur qui met
beaucoup beaucoup d'intensité dans ce
qu'il fait et on sent qu'il est qu'il
est qu'il est amoureux de ce qui fait
qu'il a vraiment envie de envie de
performer ça comme genre vraiment il y a
plus mettre des gros gros pocket que ce
soit on Ice Coulou cette saison par
moment donc moi j'aime beaucoup
l'intensité et l'amour avec lequel il
pratique le basket et je trouve qu'il a
vraiment les skills pour contourner ces
quelques limites athlétiques qui peuvent
l'empêcher d'être assez souvent Auxerre
quand on développements un meilleur
flotteur en continent progresser sur sa
capacité à finir au Cercle un excellent
petit contrôle il est capable de finir
au contact donc il a les moyens de de
palier ces quelques carences athlétiques
pour moi donc c'est un jour que j'estime
vraiment quel plafond
quel plafond pour
notre amiante George
dans le dans le meilleur des scénarios
tu as un bon deuxième porteur de balle
qui va jouer avec un allié fort qui va
pouvoir créer son propre dire débloquer
des situations compliquées
qui était un excellent athlète
verticalement automatiques aucun monstre
vertical mais mais ce genre de ce genre
de profil là ouais
Fred van beat dans le développement
pendant le corps côté un peu alors il
est un peu plus grand cranbit mais petit
enquête qui envoie beaucoup de tirs
extérieurs
donc voilà c'est ça qu'on va viser le
toujours développer de la passe c'est un
jour on l'a pas très bien dit à mais
dans son dans son dribble s'il est pas
très explosif il maîtrise au niveau des
relais demain il est capable de changer
de changer de direction de changer de
vitesse aussi et puis je les aime bien
les petits puissants tu vois ceux qui
qui passent pas tout sur leur vitesse
mais qui baisse un peu plus sur leur
corps sachant comme Thomas l'a dit son
corps il a évolué donc donc voilà faut
tomber dans un encore une fois dans un
beau contexte mais mais au pire le au
niveau du plancher tu auras voilà un
jour de rotation de banc et au mieux tu
auras peut-être un titulaire correct
dans une équipe playoffre et toi à quel
scénario tu crois du coup pour terminer
là-dessus
je crois plus dans le joueur qui va
faire de la sortie de banc à la fin
qui va être un relais 6e homme 7e homme
d'une équipe un peu compétitive voilà
qui qui va quand la star elle va sortir
ou quand le bon meneur va sortir on va
lui demander de rentrer de mettre des
tirs d'organiser un petit peu chaud du
piano rôle mais je crois pas dans le
potentiel All-Star que certains avaient
vu au niveau lycéen
Thomas toi tu tu crois en quelle tu
crois en quelle
issue est-ce que tu crois fort pas fort
tu tenais tu as déjà un petit peu
répondu mais en résumé court
en résumé court j'y crois j'y crois je
crois plus vraiment au potentiel
All-Star comme comme je pouvais
l'espérer en sortie dayschool je le
trouve quand même vraiment limité pour
créer ça de séparation à deux points
mais je trouve que la comparaison fred
va vite en plafond et pas déconnant je
pense que c'est même un meilleur
shotmaker et je trouve qu'il a un
instinct du panier vraiment vraiment
sérieux et son c'est vrai vrai gros
progrès au playmaking et même en défense
cette saison me laisse croire qu'il va
pouvoir continuer de développer et de
compléter son jeu je trouve qu'il a
décidé de chauffe il a le caractère il a
il a un corps solide même si il manque
un peu de qualité athlétique notamment
vertical par moment je pense que ça peut
être au je pense vraiment que c'est au
moins un vrai bon genre de rotation
sortie dedans et je pense qu'il va
pouvoir avoir les capacités pour être ce
choc Maker titulaire en NBA qui sait
faire mine de rien pas mal de choses et
qui peut être vraiment bien joué à côté
d'un fort Bollène de leur dominant qui
peut être un peu son soutien il peut
jouer un il peut jouer deux et c'est
défend il s'est passé c'est mettre des
tirs et là on caractère donc ouais moi
j'aime bien ouais
ce n'est pas juste les stats donc qui
ont déjà ordge des stats moyenne mais un
profil intéressant que nous avons dans
notre loterie pour le moment à envergure
et c'était donc l'essentiel sur lui
merci Thomas merci Hugues tous les
portraits à retrouver sur notre chaîne
YouTube sur notre site envergure.co et
surtout les applis d'écoute possible et
imaginables donc les plateformes plutôt
Ciao